all right guys
bang bang i've got lauren here thank you
so much for doing this sir
hey my pleasure and long time listener
absolutely well we
we've known each other for a while now
because i had the uh the pleasure of
investing in
the couple you're running right now but
we'll get to that in a second uh let's
jump right into your background
you've got a pretty interesting story
where uh you're born in israel and moved
to silicon valley
at the age of four just talk me through
growing up in silicon valley and what
that was like
sure yeah so uh you know my first
language is hebrew but i got a chance to
go to you know kindergarten and stuff in
the u.s so
pretty quickly i got americanized and me
and my brother started talking mostly
english
and i was just really lucky to land in
silicon valley because i love computers
and then later i discovered i love
entrepreneurship and i looked around and
like all the cool groups and
organizations were just right here you
know like 30 minutes drive away
everywhere i wanted to go um so yeah i
was like obsessed with computer
programming
growing up um and i studied computer
science in college
uh and then right out of college i
worked at slide which was like at the
time like i had just a random job in san
francisco slide
uh but then in retrospect it's like oh
wow there were a ton of like really
great people there who were my
co-workers
obviously max levchin uh keith roboy uh
suhail
from uh mixpanel um adora from yc just
like
crazy amount of uh good talent density
at slide and i didn't fully appreciate
it at the time
um and then i went and did a startup
called quixy which itself
got really big and partnered with
alibaba but actually we ended up
uh kind of lighting 170 million dollars
on fire
um that basically had a terrible outcome
so that was kind of my foray into the
startup world
um and then a few years ago kind of
picked up the bat for another swing
and that led me to my current company
relationship hero
so let's talk about uh lighting 170
million dollars on fire
explain kind of what happened there and
uh i think for those that aren't
familiar with startups the idea that you
could be a fast-growing big company
uh and still not work out is a little
counter-intuitive so so kind of
elaborate on that
yeah totally that's a really important
idea um it's really interesting to think
about so
um with quicksee we got really big and
this was we started
all the way back in 2009 when the iphone
was new and the whole idea of app stores
were new
and our thesis was like we need to
invent a totally different search
technology that's customized for finding
the right app now i actually think that
that's thesis there's still something to
it that's underexploited like if you use
your iphone
you know if you pull down the search bar
or the spotlight feature it's actually
still really crappy like it only
recently started finding like the most
obvious results
and it's still like barely you know if
you type in like the name of a document
you're working on it's not going to pull
up the document so that's still like a
rich area for improvement
and that was kind of the seed of quiksi
um and then but we ended up kind of uh
flailing around trying to find you know
what's the revenue model how do we get
traction
um and our biggest breakthrough came
when we partnered with alibaba
uh we made this deal where we would
power search for their app stores
um and so then that turned into like a
20 million a year revenue thing we were
doing a bunch of custom work for them
but eventually it all fell through and
so throughout the course of that whole
process
um we we raised mostly from alibaba as a
strategic investment
a total over like seven years of 170
million dollars
um and so you'd think if you're looking
at it from the outside like wow this
company is going great and all this
money's pouring in
but a lot of times it's an illusion and
you really just have to look at the
yearly metrics you know like how much
revenue is coming in
what are the costs and ours were pretty
crappy but we just had all this money to
burn anyway
and so we just burned it and then we
shut down because we didn't even have an
asset that was good enough to you know
sell and continue as
you know independently yeah and what's
so interesting about hearing this story
is uh the way that you run relationship
hero is very very data-driven
i get the updates and it's probably one
of the more data-driven updates that i
get
uh talk through a little bit about where
did the idea for relationship hero come
from and then we could talk about the
product you guys have built
totally yeah so um and yeah you're
absolutely right you know we we do a b
tests we're data driven so
the original idea it really has nothing
to do with my previous career
but it has to do with a problem that i
understand deeply which is
uh struggling with dating in
relationships um because you know you
always want to start a company around a
problem you understand
and as somebody who's always been um you
know very technical
living in silicon valley like my career
has always been an area of my life that
i have done pretty well
but my relationships were like a
disaster like i'd go on a date and it'd
be like the worst day like i'd feel
really awkward like
communication was bad like i wouldn't
get a second date um and so i found
myself always hitting up my friend like
monopolizing his time
getting all this advice about dating um
and so after
my last company shut down and i was
thinking like what problems am i
familiar
with i'm like well what if we take my
friend's skill which is basically
relationship coaching
and we scale it up and we give other
people the same benefit that i'm getting
which sounds a little crazy but as we
started to explore it's like well
everybody's trying to talk to their
friends they're trying to get
relationship advice from their friends
and it's not like they would even bother
contacting a professional because the
professionals out there just have like
these random websites
they're like you know they're not really
trustworthy they're just different types
of coaching
uh there's a lot of therapy but therapy
is you know or marriage counseling but
that's not exactly what people need
either
so we just thought hey maybe there's a
niche um so that was like the initial
kernel of the idea and
we kind of grew it organically the first
version of relationship hero was like
five of my friends
sending us screenshots of texts from
like their tinder from their okcupid
just being like hey what do i do what's
like my next move
and so as you start to build the company
uh it sounds like really in the
beginning it's almost like we're going
to do the service and then we'll figure
out what the product is over time like
how do you go from
uh what is a really uh early early kind
of mvp
to what the product has become today is
that just
constantly talking to the customers and
really understanding
uh kind of how they're using whatever
product they have in their hands and
what they need or is this more of you've
got a vision you set that vision you go
build it and then you'll find the
customers that want that thing
um it's a combination so it's a concept
that i call uh following the value
or uh the i call it the the lean mvp
flow chart so you're always trying to
follow a flow chart like in terms of
what's your next step
the rule of thumb is like well where can
i where can i double my value
like how much value am i creating now
and just how can i double it because if
you keep doubling it pretty soon you're
gonna create a lot of value
so for example like at the beginning we
were helping a few friends with text
messages
so i was like okay well to double that i
just have to find like five more friends
so pretty soon i'm helping like 10
friends okay but then i ran out of
friends
so suddenly i had to get creative i'm
like okay well how am i going to find 10
more people
and so we went on reddit and we found
some people on reddit and we were
helping them for free
um so so i'm always just thinking like
how do i just double and now we have
like thousands so doubling thousands now
we have to think like okay well now we
need to like you know do a tv commercial
or something
but if you just keep asking how do i
double how do i incrementally create
more value it gets you pretty far
yeah and so as you start to actually
build the product i remember even
early on uh you're playing with like the
monetization and kind of the pricing
structure and at what point it was like
i think a dollar per minute
and then you move more to like a monthly
type structure just talk through like
maybe some of the tests that you would
run and kind of what data you would pay
attention to in order to better
understand
you know what works what doesn't work
and kind of what's in the best interest
of our customers long term
totally yeah so one thing we do is we
just we a b test like crazy so like any
time we launch anything we have it uh
deeply embedded into our software
that everything is an a b test you know
like uh and i'm not just talking about
like button colors a lot of times we
actually don't bother testing like the
really small stuff that we don't think
is going to matter
but anytime we're trying to say like hey
can we raise our prices
well what if we were to offer uh we
raise our prices but we give half the
people
a discount and we see if the the people
with a discount uh actually tend to sign
up with a with a higher rate
you know and so we're always looking at
the numbers because how lame is it to
like launch something
and that you know cuts 25 out of your
business and you don't even realize it
and you blame it on seasonality you know
it's not like
you need the instrument panel of a b
test yeah
and so this idea uh is pretty
you know straightforward right it's hey
people want a relationship advice we're
going to provide relationship advice
but you've built it in a unique almost
like marketplace way where
uh you're bringing in top of funnel
interest of people who need the advice
and then you're basically finding people
uh who could be the coaches and
onboarding them in order to uh to
provide a good experience
why has nobody else done it in this way
right like where did uh the
insight come from to do it in this
specific um
kind of uh virtual uh you know
technology-enabled way come from yeah
definitely so
it's you know relationship here it's
it's not necessarily what it seems on
the surface like when people see us
they're just like oh you're a
marketplace
but what most people don't realize is
that uh there's not really a market for
relationship coaches
so like you can compare us to better
help in talk space on the therapy side
those apps are much more like a
marketplace because they take something
that's a more standard commodity
like a therapist okay you make a list of
what certifications
it constitutes a therapist and then you
go offer a contract drop to those people
so that would be more of a marketplace
model
in our case there's no such thing as a
certified relationship coach
with a single definition so we looked at
all the certifications out there
and we're like okay well this one kind
of fits but it's missing this
and eventually we pull together our own
certification and our own training
and then we're like okay great so we
know how to train and certify a
relationship coach
but then you know where do we find them
or like who are these relationship
coaches
um and so we started kind of looking for
raw talent so we have people you know we
have a list of like 20
backgrounds that are all like somewhat
relevant like okay this person has done
social work this person has a ba in
psychology
so we have all these different
backgrounds and then we train them and
so
we're we're kind of in this middle space
i guess there's a fancy term for this
we're like a managed marketplace
where we have a lot of control over our
supply in fact uh in the u.s
we we have the coaches are actually
full-time w-2 employees
got it and and so as you started to
scale this up
what's been the biggest learning in
terms of actually building out
uh you know in a space that people i
think uh understood but
using a model that uh people hadn't done
before
um yeah so it's you know it's really
just thinking from first principles
right so
instead of i feel like people are always
like trying to search google and try to
find like the answer for how to do
something but in our case we're just
like well
can this person give good coaching and
if they did how could we tell like what
would be the proof
so we like made a bunch of tests they
have to take tests and then we have
a dashboard showing like uh what does
their retention look like you know like
do the clients come back
what kind of reviews do they leave and
so when we hire and train a new coach we
can see very quickly like within a
couple weeks like
where they stand and we can instantly
detect anomalies being like okay
something's wrong with their coaching
and the unique thing about what we do is
we take responsibility for the quality
of the coaching
so like if you got bad advice we'll
actually go in and look and be like oh
okay let me give you a refund let me
actually
give you a more senior coach to kind of
fix the bad advice you got
and it's rare but we we take
responsibility when that happens
and why is the focus so much on what
i'll call like very tactical things
right so this isn't hey be nice or hey
you should go do something at a high
level
it's very very tactical and like you
should respond in this way or you should
do
uh x thing uh on why date why the focus
on the tactical aspect rather than
more high level stuff sure yeah well
imagine you're going to your friends for
relationship help
right a lot of what you need is that
tactical advice
and the thing is that it's possible to
be an expert on
relationship tactics you know courtship
uh courtship is
a game right and it has a lot of evolved
strategies and tactics
um you know like crafting the perfect
text you have to draw on a lot of
communication skills
and everybody feels like they have to be
their own expert right everybody's like
oh yeah i don't need help you know
dating it just comes from my heart it's
just me being authentic
and so one of the the perspectives that
we have about relationship hero which we
think
is not super popular yet but we think
it's growing in popularity
is the idea of like look sure you want
to be authentic but you shouldn't expect
yourself to have all these communication
and courtship skills because it's
something that you can like invest more
time into getting better
and you can talk to a professional and
get some tips that'll save you a lot of
time
and the most important question i'm
gonna ask you today
uh everyone wants to know how do you
write the perfect text message or
tinder message yeah definitely so
uh you know i'm not going to give you a
bunch of stock openers although we do
have those
um the number one key that people just
don't get like the most common complaint
i hear about dating apps is like
you send a message even you work hard on
it and you know you express
why you like the other person and then
you don't get a reply or
you got a few replies but then the
conversation like peter's up you're like
damn i like this person like the
conversation peter out
and the number one trick um to to
keeping the conversation going
in like a really good serendipitous way
is you just have to think a couple moves
ahead
like think about it like it's chess you
know like playing chess against yourself
imagine that you are the recipient of
the text and imagine that
you uh just want to be able to respond
within like five seconds like a response
just comes to your head like it's
natural banter
most of the texts that people write are
actually really annoying to respond to
and the only way to respond to it is to
like think for five minutes
and when you make the other person think
for five minutes they're like uh you
know this guy seems pretty cool but
it's just let me let me get back to them
and then they never get back to you
yeah it's so fascinating that uh you
describe it as
chess because basically what you're
trying to do is not
uh ask a question that has a finite
answer it sounds like instead what
you're doing is you're really asking a
question to elicit a
response in which you can then respond
to again and kind of keep the
conversation going right it's almost
like you're optimizing for
a sustained conversation rather than
simply uh getting information
yes except uh you know when you say
sustained conversation it's not just
about like prolonging it it's about
making each back and forth uh feel good
basically or
or give some value or have some purpose
um so for example
like when it's early in the conversation
a lot of times you just want to make
them engage and like have fun
so your goal is basically to create a
fun interaction so you want to throw in
like a tease or a joke
but not just like a random knock-knock
joke but like a certain type of joke
where
they like it and also they're motivated
to continue it like
something that like challenges them a
little bit like kind of like an
interactive role play
i love the uh the just the framework
that you use to describe this
uh i want to switch gears um and we'll
come back to relationship here in a
little bit but
uh there's a lot of people who listen to
this who like uh bitcoin
and technology investing you've been
early to a lot of things there's this
tweet from 2011
june 11 2011 and it says my investment
thesis buy into a 10
probability of 100x return examples one
bitcoin two milliner and conway's start
fund
uh there weren't very many people who
were talking about bitcoin and 100x
uh potential upside uh back in 2011
when did you first hear about bitcoin
why did you uh kind of tweet that out
and kind of what was the logic back then
as best you remember it
yeah yeah definitely and by the way
don't forget milner and conway's start
fund i remember
yuri milner and ron conway back in 2011
gave y combinator a ton of money they
were invested a lot in every company
and that ship has actually come in too
right like if you look at all these ipos
like airbnb
almost 100 billion like everybody now
realizes that y combinator
is by far like the best game in town
except maybe sequoia
like those two are so yeah i mean i i
think both y combinator and bitcoin were
like really
sleeper hits back in 2011. um and and so
so where did i get the thesis i just
think that uh you know the human brain
is just bad with orders of magnitude
right so i'm always looking for the 10
probability and back in 2011
bitcoin there was like a 90 chance that
it was just gonna like fizzle out right
like now obviously it's it's much more
robust but in 2011 sure it might fizzle
out
but i just noticed like okay well on the
10 chance that it doesn't fizzle out
like couldn't it just go 10x 100x 1000x
like
isn't that you know why isn't that
possible if it can go 3x why not 100x
and like
sure enough you know the 100x was like
well within the realm of possibility
yeah and in terms of that technology
versus a fund how did you look at the
difference or even today how do you look
at the difference between
uh basically giving money to somebody
else to go invest versus finding the
assets yourself
sure yeah i mean they're both good
strategies right so i i tend to i just
think that my comparative advantage is
noticing
um i call it order of magnitude
perspective so my brain is just wired in
such a way where i'm always trying to
like ask you know how big is something
i'm just like really obsessed with with
like order of magnitude size right so i
just noticed hey bitcoin could be really
big right you know that very well like
you're always talking you know it could
be a hundred trillion one day
um and so yeah so that was the the deal
with bitcoin um and also
one connection i have to bitcoin that's
kind of random like what was i even
doing looking at it in 2011
um a couple random historical accidents
from my life
one is that when i was in college
studying computer science i randomly
took this
grad grad class graduate level elective
and we were talking about cryptography
and
i randomly did a project like writing a
little paper um
on on this research paper where somebody
had made a scheme
for it was called compact e-cash so it
was like a way to use principles of
cryptography to pay people so like i did
a little report on the scheme i did a
little presentation i'm like yeah
this is a nice little scheme but it's
like impractical so it basically sucks
but it's like a nice idea
um so then literally like two years
later i'm reading the bitcoin white
paper and like wait a minute
this is like the the crappy paper that i
read in college except like
much better solving all these problems
so like i just randomly happen to be in
a position of being like oh holy crap
like this is like a
solution an important problem um and
then the other thing that that really
hit for me is
i was part of the lesswrong.com
community you know all these
rationalists
um and they were actually very early to
bitcoin in fact there's like
some there's some gossip that uh that
one of the contributors one or two of
the contributors
to less wrong might be satoshi so like
they're and
they were talking about bitcoin and so
the last straw for me
after those two like data points was
just seeing it
seeing the market price start to rise
like seeing it get traction seeing it
get talked about and not die
and i'm like okay if on the conceptual
level bitcoin is so powerful
and it's not going away socially like
it's actually picking up steam in terms
of like normal people caring about it
um then that is like a very potent
combination
yeah you also were a an early investor
in coinbase
uh and so for somebody who saw bitcoin
so early was it just a natural extension
when you met brian
uh that coinbase could be big or kind of
what was the story there and why did you
invest
so randomly in 2012 when i was kind of
like at the height of my bitcoin
obsession like i'm actually less
involved with bitcoin these days but um
right around that time
um there was this uh this new company
called funders club which is uh really
great they're actually doing really well
too
um and it was this new idea of like
letting people give smaller checks a
little bit like a syndicate
uh letting people put smaller checks
into companies and that was right when i
was starting to get a little bit of
disposable income
and i was looking to do a little angel
investing so just by coincidence i
i ended up putting a check into the
first funders club fund
where they had a few options of
companies to pick and i'm like oh yeah
coinbase i like bitcoin
so a lot of luck you know silicon valley
being the right place at the right time
happening to like bitcoin
ended up angel investing in coinbase and
then of course you know forgot about it
for a few years and and now they're like
you know the next uh potential yc ipo
and i've just been really impressed oh
my thesis there was just like look i
think bitcoin's a big deal and i think
that coinbase is doing a really good job
at just being like the best bitcoin
company yeah
and it's so funny because once you make
the investment you kind of forget about
it for a while
it's almost as if you give your capital
to an entrepreneur and you test them
with like hey go grow my wealth
right to some degree and being in the
yc silicon valley type world was there
additional weight put on it that they
were going through yc or had gone
through yc i don't know
at what point um or was it just i just
like this company
uh so the yc stamp of approval
definitely meant a lot to me so yc has
like a special place in my heart because
i was reading paul graham
essays when i was in high school um just
like obsessively even before
uh yc was a thing and then i kind of
followed y.c from afar like you know
read all the
uh all the articles documenting what was
happening in yc eventually relationship
hero ended up doing
yc in 2017 so i kind of got to check off
a bucket list item
but yeah when i saw coinbase do yc that
was definitely another plus
but at the same time it was really funny
to consider like how clueless i was as
an angel investor because coinbase is my
best angel investment so
i like to act like i know what i'm doing
but it was really like my first lucky
angel investment and i was like
i was just like chatting with them being
like oh yeah let me let me analyze your
code you know
what programming image are you writing
and just like you know just didn't
really know how to evaluate a company
it's so funny what was going through yc
like
um it was pretty cool so you know it's
the it's just i built up so much
anticipation and i read so much about yc
that when it actually happened
it was slightly anti-climactic because
it's like oh yeah right okay it's yc
um if i felt like i was like super
hardcore i was like okay i have to talk
with every partner i have to like you
know go contact every company like
i was like so hyped up about it and like
other people were like more calm so
let's settle down um but but no i mean
it's
really good they give you high quality
advice um we we always get
you know nuggets of insight from our
advisors like when we started
relationship hero we're actually focused
only on text chat and so one thing our
our partners told us is like hey you
know have them give you a call
and so like on the way to a yc uh group
advising session we
um my co-founder leor was like on the
phone giving coaching to one of our
clients you know so
they give you great advice um obviously
the the application the straightforward
application process and the
straightforward
125k that they give you is nice um the
stamp of approval is nice so
i mean yc is is killing it you know
they're number one
yeah it's so fascinating to see kind of
just
success after success and you wonder how
much of that is the selection bias
versus
the actual value that they derive what
would you say was the the best part of
the experience and then the worst part
of the experience
uh okay the best part of the experience
um i would just have to say how good
they are at helping you raise more money
right it's it's really amazing what they
do i think everybody knows right you
come in at a valuation that's less than
two million right when when they give
you money you're valued less than two
million
uh they get seven percent of the company
and by the time you're pitching on demo
day
uh we raised that six million you know
these days companies are raising at 10
12
15 right 20 is not unheard of um and so
so it's kind of like they 10xy like in
three months right it's talk about a 10x
return
um and so so yeah so that magical
process worked on us to some degree i
mean it was still
it was still hard work to meet with a
bunch of investors and raise money but
you know they absolutely gave us a boost
and that's probably
uh if i had to rank the reasons to do yc
i just think
the fact that they open doors to talk
with so many investors is probably their
number one value
um the worst part of yc i guess i might
have to say like um
randomly when you have to go listen to
the talks because sometimes the talks
are a really special
part of yc like i really like seeing uh
joe gebbia from airbnb like he talked to
us and i was really cool you know drew
from dropbox
but some of the talks were like we were
less excited about and we even skipped
them because
we were like an hour away like uh when
yc was a non-viewer in san francisco
and then they like oh why don't you come
into the talks i'm like well i watch so
many startup talks i don't want to see
every talk so i kind of opted out of
some of the talks
that's awesome uh you've got a blog uh
you've worked on for a while bloated
mvp what was the thought process behind
that oh yeah bloated mvp so
um you know i like to write but i've
never found until now like a theme that
i can write a bunch of articles about
um so bloated mvp is like the first time
when i'm like i bet i can write like 50
articles about bloated mvps
uh and the concept obviously mvp stands
for minimum viable product
um and so bloated mvp is kind of like
another
synonym for um for a startup that's not
a lean startup
right like if you if you try to follow
eric reese's lean startup and you try to
make an mvp
but you fail at it you end up with a
bloated mvp and the reason why i want to
write about bloated mvps is i think even
today when everybody knows
you're supposed to make an mvp right
it's like it's already seeped into the
culture and yet
80 of companies that i see are bloated
mvps i'm like what's going on why is
everybody still shooting themselves in
the foot
so i made a blog explodedmvp.com and it
just documents like okay here's another
startup shooting themselves in the foot
making uploaded mvp
um and it's so easy not to make a
bloated mvp if you follow like a few
principles
um so that's basically what i spell out
why do why is it so easy to
mess it up like why does everyone
continue to launch these bloated mvps
so yeah there's actually a bunch of
reasons because you you think you know
the concept is so well taught you think
everybody would get it by now
um there's a bunch of factors that lead
you astray for example even the word
mvp minimum viable product the word
product i think is actually very
misleading like remember how i said
relationship hero it started out as like
uh me and my co-founder just helping
five of our friends okay how did we help
five of our friends they would text us
screenshots or we made a facebook group
and we'd post in the facebook group
right would you call that a product no
but it was
us giving value to our friends so i
would still call it a value
transaction and what people don't
understand is it when you want to build
a company from nothing
you have to follow the value and you
have to ask yourself how do i create a
little bit of value
how do i double the value right how do i
create more value and when you do all
that
that's not necessarily a product but
what most founders do is they're kind of
you know they're
they're cargo quilting right so they're
copying the the surface level
characteristics and like okay
here's my startup i got to get a
co-founder i got to get a accelerator i
got to get a you know
vc an angel i gotta check all these
boxes to do a start and then i gotta
hire a developer or learn learn to code
right and then i have to build a website
launch in the app store and go to
product on and everybody's just like
you know they're like zombies right or
like lemmings right it's like no forget
all that stuff just follow the value
yeah and it's crazy too because i think
that it's so easy to
get lost in the weeds and want to build
you know feature after feature after
feature
uh but also there's a psychological
element to it right like yes you want to
make the product as good as you can
but it's also scary to launch something
that you know isn't good
right to some degree so how do you think
people get over that
yeah definitely um there's a few tips so
one of them is the idea that like nobody
cares i mean there are certain like high
profile launches
that like naturally hype up right so
like if a well-known entrepreneur
is gonna go launch something i actually
think you know marissa mayer launched
something the other day and she's so
high profile
that she would probably have to launch
it anonymously if she wanted to get like
you know some early
feedback and iterate but for 99 of
entrepreneurs including myself
um people care so little about what you
launched they just cares a little it's
like people imagine that they're going
to launch
and they're going to get like a million
people's like the intense spotlight on
them there's not going to be a spotlight
on you like you should be so lucky
that a bunch of people will care to
judge your product so just like launch
it and see what happens
yeah and the downside really isn't that
bad because there's so little people
using it that if it
absolutely sucks and everyone hates it
uh you'll learn and you know what they
say feedback is a gift
right i want to talk a little bit about
uh
modern rationality uh this is fascinates
me
uh you've been kind enough to uh to
suggest a couple of guests to come on
the podcast previously that touch on
this stuff
just maybe let's start at a high level
like what is modern rationality
yeah sure so rationality is really
awesome and it's fun to talk about
because there's like so many
misperceptions about it so i have to
give credit to you know where i learned
all the concepts of modern rationality
probably centered around that site i
mentioned lesswrong.com
but there's also you know
overcomingbias.com which is uh robin
hansen's personal blog and and yeah he
was on the podcast
uh i highly recommend uh listening to
his episode um but unless wrong.com was
actually founded by
eliezer yudkowski who is somebody who
he's like very prominent in the
artificial intelligence research
community and one of the inventors of
modern rationality and
he wrote this thing called the sequences
which is like many thousands of pages of
like
dense explanatory content of like all
these different ways
of like how to think and um how to
properly change your mind like exactly
when the evidence tells you to change
your mind basically like how to do
science better
um so like very high level like what
what is all the stuff right like what's
the what's the central idea
it's basically like how to wield your
brain as a tool because obviously your
brain is like extremely powerful right
it's like the most intelligent object in
the known universe right
but at the same time it did just evolve
right it wasn't designed it evolved
and the way that it evolved was like you
know to survive and reproduce
right so like it's it's not your brain
is not designed to like
see truth and have accurate beliefs it's
just designed to like
let you get by in society and so
rationality is about trying to like
you know remove the all the filters and
just be like well what if i wanted to
use my brain as a tool for like
clearly seeing the world and like making
discoveries you know how do i do that
better
and as you do this and kind of learn
this way of thinking is it practice
makes perfect
and you just gotta really kind of
you know throw yourself off the deep end
and just obsess
over as much of the content as possible
and you pick up kind of muscle memory
uh or is it something where you somebody
can sit down read for you know five
hours
get it and then they're off to the races
it's a good question like how does one
actually become more rational and one of
the principles of modern rationality is
that
a lot of times it helps to focus on a
problem so don't just focus on the
rationality itself but like focus like
you're trying to solve a problem
um you know for for example like if
you're trying to go to the moon
that that necessarily means you have to
get rational about like how orbits work
you know what i'm saying like there's
you have to kind of chain backwards and
you have to
you also have to get rational about like
you have to think how do i design a
protocol to test different iterations of
my rocket engine
you see what i'm saying like not only do
you have to understand the physics of
the engine but you have to step back a
level and you have to think like
how do i organize a bunch of humans to
build a rocket engine and when it
doesn't work
how do i tell them to like evaluate the
data and try again
and like when when should we do the
experiment you know like should we put a
bunch of parts together and test them
all at once
so it keeps making you step back and
rationality is kind of like the ultimate
stepping back of like you know how do i
organize everything to begin with
yeah and it feels also like uh there's a
mental framework right that you can
apply to almost every situation
but really this depends on this like
intellectual curiosity to continue to
drive towards
um you know whether it's first
principles thinking or
really getting at the root of a problem
and so it almost feels like what you're
doing is you're trying to
stoke uh or build up that intellectual
curiosity muscle
while also developing these frameworks
in which to
apply it so that when you're looking at
a problem uh you're not kind of getting
caught by all the shiny things and
you're really finding the meat of of the
issue
yes so there's really it's a whole
toolbox of frameworks there's like so
many greatest hits of rationality
um so one of them is just the idea of
like uh changing your mind is good
so like imagine two people go into an
argument a lot of times both people are
like well this is what i believe
and this is what he believes and we're
both going to try to convince each other
so one of the things of rationality is
is the idea of like well
if you're really just trying to have a
more accurate belief
you should think of it like a dance you
know almost like a martial art where you
come in
and inside of your brain is a
probability distribution
over possible ways that you think that
the world might be and as you interact
with somebody else
the stuff they say you take it in and
you want that stuff to update your
mental model like you wanna
you want to let your mind be changed um
you know when when
if your current mental model is not
accurate you want to let it get more
accurate by changing
right so not every change is going to be
an improvement but every improvement
improvement is going to be a change
so that's the kind of stuff rationality
tells you and in order to pull that off
they
they have like countless uh you know
bags of tricks that help you do that
just uh i'll give you one that i think
is really profound for me which is just
the tool of specificity
which is just like when you hear an
argument before you get really reactive
to the argument
try to zoom in and drill down and make
it more specific
so i've written about an example on my
blog like imagine
that like i'm somebody who's like pro
capitalism right but
and and i think uber is like an overall
good company but i know it's like kind
of controversial
um and so somebody will come up and tell
me like you know what i don't like about
uber
uber exploits its workers and so i'm
tempted to say
well you know in capitalism anytime
you're giving somebody an offer of
employment you're just making a bid in a
market and so they can take or leave the
bid but overall it's driving wages up
right because they're bidding for labor
and they can always get a different so
anyway so that's
that's my temptation is to give this
high level answer but here's a
rationality trick i learned before i
even give any answer
i can stop and be like okay uber expects
its workers can we get more specific
about that can you tell me
a hypothetical story of like one person
and just describe in detail how they're
getting exploited
and they say okay well imagine a guy
named joe who
wants to earn a few bucks so he takes a
job at uber
um and uber pay uh he ends up making 13
an hour and he drives around and his car
gets some uh depreciation
and he doesn't get benefits i'm like
okay and and then
and the guy's like well and meanwhile
uber's ipoing and they're making 80
billion and joe's like making 13
minus depreciation i'm like okay well is
that really exploitation like what's
what what's joe's next best alternative
like well joe could go get an actual job
with benefits i'm like okay then but why
didn't he
and like i don't know i didn't i'm like
well you have to tell me why you didn't
because you're you're telling a story
i'm just asking you to tell me a
specific story like you can go ahead and
flesh out the detail like i'm just
trying to listen
and then when they try to flesh it out
they're like well maybe uh burger king
offered them benefits and uber's not
offering them benefits
i'm like okay so is that why they're
exploiting they're not offering benefits
so i'm not saying i'm going to win the
argument but i'm saying just by being
really specific about like what they're
even talking about
a lot of times they're not talking about
anything coherent and their argument
just kind of like collapses
i love the idea of just keep asking why
and how and why and how and really
really pulling out the uh the individual
details
right one area where uh i don't think we
are yet able to do that is super
intelligent
uh artificial intelligence and um you
know
you've told me that that is a big topic
among this uh
rational uh community help me understand
kind of what is the obsession there and
kind of what are those conversations
about
yeah totally um so really important
topic and it's actually you know uh i
mentioned that eleazar yatkowski
the creator of lesterong.com is somebody
who's big in both the ai community and
the rationality community
his initial motivation for teaching the
world about rationality
is because he realized that um he wasn't
getting enough traction
educating the world about artificial
intelligence risk because he needed to
like first step back and be like listen
this is how you need to use your brain
okay now that your brain is fixed let me
tell you about ai risk so
that was like his course of events um
and so
the argument for iris luckily it's been
getting a lot of traction
and so if you compare you know today if
i say hey ai is risky we need to study
ai risk a lot of people nod their heads
they're like yes it is kind of risky
yeah
if i said this 10 years ago that would
it would just kind of sound like a very
random fringe topic to bring up so
it's definitely becoming more mainstream
you know elon musk has said yes we need
to study ai risk
um but but what is exactly the risk so
very simply it's just the idea that um
it's uh it's very possible to imagine an
ai that's really smart
and doesn't mind accidentally destroying
a bunch of stuff like
destroying life as we know it like it's
kind of easily it's kind of easy to
accidentally destroy
life as we know it like for example like
imagine if you just like if you took
like a random animal
like a badger and you just scaled up the
badger until its capabilities are
like you know more than a nation state
well you can imagine the badger might
accidentally destroy the world like it
doesn't if it doesn't
you know consciously try not to um so
that's kind of like uh super intelligent
ai
you know similar kind of risk yeah it's
fascinating in terms of
uh there's a line between hey we need
this it's going to make us so much
better at
xyz activity and then there's a quick
turnover that hill and then it becomes
hey we should really fear this thing
like it could kill us all
where do you think that line is and how
much of a
validity do you put in the idea of super
intelligent ai risk
um yeah so i i actually think it's a
really really important big risk um
remember we were talking about uh you
know like the 10
chance of 100x return and i was talking
about order of magnitude perspective
like your ability to notice when
something is like a big deal
so ai risk is a very very big deal and
the chance of it is actually a lot more
than 10
and the the return of getting it right
versus wrong is like a lot more than 100
x
so it's a very very very big deal um and
so people are just they're having a hard
time intuitively getting it because when
you look at ai today it's like okay it
classified an image
and people say all these smug comments
like you know oh you know alpha alphago
can play go
but if i were facing it in real life i
could take out a gun and shoot it right
or like i could turn it off i think neil
degrasse tyson like i'll find the off
switch or whatever but it's like
uh no like it just it doesn't work like
that like it's so
it's so easy um conceptually for the ai
to be like well
i'm going to manufacture a nanobot like
but you know by sending you know there's
labs right now that are connected to the
internet
that have enough tooling to you know to
start there there's biology labs
connected to the internet right now
right so
and you saw how like you know today we
have um the modern uh
vaccine right it's mrna so they just
coded some mrna and you put it into your
body and it's and it's uh it basically
programs your body
okay well if an ai were sufficiently
smart it would just have to be connected
to the internet to start doing
bioengineering like you could pay with
bitcoin
it could build these things and the
problem with nanobots is you know
this is just one thing they can do i'm
not saying they will i'm just giving you
a possibility like nanobots
the problem is they can replicate a
bunch and you can end up with like the
entire earth turned into
nanobots like pretty quickly because of
exponential growth so i'm just saying
there's a lot of power here that you can
unlock
if the right code is running on the
internet
yeah and what's crazy to me is like
everything you just said there's
90 of people or more will be like that's
crazy like there's no way nanobots are
gonna be running around doing all this
stuff but whatever
but actually no there is a possibility
and uh i always
you know push people on the probability
and then the asymmetric payoff so
bitcoin's a great example
you know uh five years ago probability
of it succeeding
still pretty low like low single digits
probably
but very very high asymmetric payoff if
it works right it'll be very big kind of
that order of magnitude that you're
talking about uh this is even
bigger and worse right like the
probability of that happening is
probably even
lower which means that the asymmetric uh
opportunity
is even more egregious and therefore
uh it i guess that's really where kind
of you drive like hey people should
really be paying attention to this
even though it's a low probability
because the risk is so big
well funny enough i actually think it's
pretty high probability too
why why do you think that um so there's
a few things um so one is just the idea
of the uh
uh okay first let's start with what are
the chances that computers are going to
get smarter than humans and i think
that's like 80 or 90
right like it's hard for me to imagine
that like a hundred or a thousand years
from now we're not
the human brain is still going to be the
smartest thing that doesn't sound
plausible to me because computers are
rapidly getting more intelligent and
capable
yeah well and i guess really that it
comes like time frame right so it's like
if there's a
larger probability it's just on what
time frame is that uh
in our lifetime is that in the next you
know 200 years or is that
10 000 years right yeah so i i think
it's probably in our lifetime and it
it's i would say it's within like you
know a few years to
one or two lifetimes like i i would be
pretty shocked if 200 years from now we
still don't have smarter than human
intelligence i'd be like really like
what happened
do you think that means that we
shouldn't develop super intelligent ai
like should we just stop
there's a good tactical argument to say
we should just stop but it's also the
problem is stopping requires a ton of
coordination because
it's not you know back in uh when they
were doing the manhattan project like in
the 40s
um you could argue you know you kind of
needed a nation state to like enrich
uranium or whatever so you could just be
like okay let's ban enriching
uranium and we can you know same as we
try to do with arms control today
but when it comes to making an ai it
could literally just be like
a team of like less than 10 really smart
people in a basement with a computer
like there's no way to force them to
stop even if the law says to stop
yeah it's uh it's pretty crazy when you
think back to uh rationality
uh are you able to apply these concepts
on a daily basis or is this more like a
framework
um that you just use as you kind of go
through the higher level decisions in
your life
i personally find that i'm able to apply
it quite a lot
um just probably my favorite thing to
apply besides what i said about like
making people get specific
besides that one my other favorite thing
to apply is just like
throw out a numerical guess even if it's
vague as hell it's like with bitcoin you
know bitcoin back in 2011 when most
people see that they'd be like yeah it
has a very low chance
um and then they would leave it at that
but what i did was i said like okay well
is the chance more like point zero zero
one percent is it more like one percent
is more like ten percent is more like
fifty percent and i said oh it's about
ten percent
right like where did i get that number
right out of my rear right it's like i i
where did i get ten percent but i just
think ten percent is a better guess than
one percent or fifty percent
and making that guess it lets you make
another guess of like well is the upside
is the maximum possible upside is it 10x
100x 1000x and i'm like okay let's say a
thousand or ten thousand x
so then what i have to do is just
multiply 10 percent by let's say 1000x
suddenly i get this number you know uh
100x and like wow okay well that the
expected value is 100x
sounds like a good investment to put a
little bit of cash into um and that's
useful thinking and so i mentioned that
in the concept of investing but you can
even do it in the concept
context of work like should i do this
project right like what's the can this
project 10x my company if it works
what's the chance of it working can it
1.2 can it grow my company 20
so i'm always making these vague
numerical calculations and i find that
they're
they're more useful to do that than not
yeah
let's talk about relationship hero to uh
to finish up as you
built the company obviously you've got
this framework of rationality um
you've been early to a lot of different
technology trends where do you think
relationship
uh hero is going and kind of how do you
think about the path to get to that
kind of final vision yeah totally so i
think
you know the big vision of relationship
hero is there just needs to be a really
big relationship coaching industry like
it needs to be like a
10 to 50 billion a year industry um
funny enough you can look to our
neighbor therapy right so therapy
already is a 30 million
industry in the u.s and uh or a 7
million
industry 30 million americans go to
therapy so you already have like 10 of
the population going to therapy
and so ask yourself what percent of the
population would benefit from a
relationship coach
well imagine like anybody you talk to
ask them to make a pie chart being like
in this pie chart like make a pie chart
of all the things you care about
life and like how much value they are
for you know for your whole life a big
slice of the pie is going to be their
relationships
right so suddenly you've got like you
know 300 million americans they all care
about their relationships
and so where do they go for relationship
help instead of going to their friends
they should go
to a relationship coach so the vision
for relationship here is to just take
what we've been doing now for like 50
000 clients
and scale it up to like 50 million
clients yeah and
in terms of how big it could be do you
think it can be bigger than the 7
billion dollar
kind of therapy market or do you think
that it's probably about the same size
um well i think that it's within an
order of magnitude
right so i don't think it's going to be
more than 10 times bigger but i also
think that it's not going to be more
than 10 times smaller so i think it's
going to like maybe it'll be like 50
bigger um and i think you know a lot of
people need therapy and therapy is great
but for me if i had to guess i would
actually think that more people could
use
a little bit of relationship help
compared to a therapist but i don't
think that they need to be compared
because i think that they're both good
and they're the same order of magnitude
but if i had to pick one i'm going to
say a relationship patch for sure and
somebody who uses the product today
what is the experience like from uh from
a user's perspective
um so we make it as convenient as
possible so if you want to do a video
call with a relationship coach
if you just want to text them if you
want to get on the phone you pick you
just go to relationshiphero.com
actually since you're watching the pomp
podcast you can go to
relationshiphero.com
uh and we'll give you fifty dollars off
i gotta you know i gotta do the promo
um and then you you just you schedule an
appointment we do same-day appointments
oftentimes like within an hour you could
be talking uh and you can just say your
issue
we have a money-back guarantee um and
you know the the reason why we're
uh we're able to run this business and
have it be profitable is because we have
an extremely high satisfaction rate
where a lot of times people come in
feeling stuck but then they report to us
like oh wow you really opened my eyes
like this this coaching was like
surprisingly valuable for the time and
money i spent
so that's why we think we're on to
something yeah and what's so fascinating
about this i think
is uh not only one is there that money
back guarantee
uh you've put thousands of people
through it um the discount obviously
relationshiphero.com which everyone
appreciates
uh but also there's a very quick
feedback
loop right like there's sometimes people
say like hey come and use my product or
service and like
you know six months from now you'll know
if it works or not like that's pretty
hard to sell
for you guys a lot of times it's
literally within hours or days somebody
will know immediately like either this
is helpful to me or not
um and so that high satisfaction
um kind of rating really drives home the
point that like this is working for
thousands and thousands of people
yes you know it's very interesting about
relationship advice because
it's very hard to give the right advice
but
when you hear that you're getting good
advice um a lot of times even without
being an expert
you can feel that you're getting good
advice like when you hear it you're like
oh yeah that actually makes a lot of
sense even though i didn't think about
it so even within the same session
you're already getting some feedback
from your brain being like this is
making sense
i love it uh before i let you go ask
everyone the same two questions
first is what is the most important book
that you've ever read
um well i have to say the the uh the
consolidated sequences from less wrong
and actually uh if you go to
lesswrong.com now they just for the
first time ever uh published the less
wrong sequences
uh as a book and they published a
collection from last year's less wrong
essay so i guess i'm going to promote
les wrongs book because it really is
i've read everything
three times over and we're talking
thousands of pages so i want to put in a
bug for them
and they put it as a book that you can
just buy
exactly yeah it's like a physical book
it's a kindle book yeah lesswrong.com
all right people should definitely go
check that out uh second question
aliens uh are you a believer or a
non-believer
man so i heard you asked this to robin
robin hansen and he gave such a good
thorough answer
so i'm not gonna top robin hansen's
answer um
but i i'll give my like dumber take i
guess which is
um i think that in the observable
universe it's pretty obvious that
there's no alien activity
just because if if they if they were
really smart and serious like they would
obviously be like harvesting all the
resources they wouldn't leave the stars
out there to just like burn themselves
out that's like a massive waste of
resources for example
um but i think that uh if there's
there's probably aliens um right outside
us in terms of like computer simulation
levels
so like i'm definitely and you might
want to ask this question instead of
just asking hair there and lindsey
should be like are we in a simulation
because
if i had to guess gun in my head are we
in a simulation yes or no i think i'd
say yes
just because think about this we're
we're in an era where we're inventing
virtual reality right
so i can basically put on virtual
reality goggles and feel like i'm in a
simulation
so it's like we're inventing simulations
this technology is just becoming
possible we're gonna start like
there's gonna be people who spend their
whole lives in vr and yet you're telling
me there's no other aliens who have
invented a simulation and put us
in it they just we just happen to be in
a time when simulations are getting
invented like it seems like too big of a
coincidence to me
so one of the craziest parts about me
asking the question about aliens is
one how many people believe aliens are
real like 90 plus percent probably maybe
95
uh of people who come on it to the point
where it's shocking to me when someone
says no now
um that completely inverts when you ask
about simulations
it's like less than five percent of
people think that simulation is real uh
and what i wonder is how much of it has
to do with like the socialization
uh and the political correctness of
these ideas right so like
aliens 20 years ago like you were the
crazy person if you talked about aliens
now it's like
dude the government has ufo videos and
you know all this kind of stuff and so
now aliens have become much more
acceptable to talk about and believe in
publicly uh simulation my guess is
10 20 years from now uh will be very
similar it's just
at the moment uh not quite as popular of
an idea to
uh to to um you know kind of embrace as
maybe aliens are
yeah the overton window has embraced
aliens but not quite simulation
absolutely uh you could ask me one
question to finish up what do you got
for me
cool so pump i've kind of watched you
build up your podcast and your audience
and it's very impressive
um so my question is what's been your
most effective strategy for growing your
audience
consistency not even close it's
literally
uh just doing it over and over and over
and over again day in day out
for years uh and that sounds like too
simplistic for most people
but uh you know when i first started a
lot of people forget like
we didn't have video on youtube uh we
literally were really really bad uh
at the audio stuff we didn't know what
we were doing um
and the guests kind of were all over the
place in terms of some like really high
quality guests
some that just somebody emailed me was
like hey i want to come on your podcast
i was like sweet
you know that must mean it's legit like
you know bring somebody on um
but as we've improved i think the
quality uh
the guests all that kind of stuff what i
realize is like
a lot of the most diehard loyal
listeners and readers and things like
that for everything that i do
came from the early days like it didn't
matter that it wasn't high quality
uh in terms of production and all that
like it was just the fact that i kept
putting out the content
uh and they got value out of it right
and that's why they stayed but
i think the consistency by far is the
number one thing that uh
that i've learned and you know that's
always my advice to other people is like
hey if you want to do this like
first piece of advice don't do it
because you literally have to be
consistent for
you know years and years and years i
think i've been doing it now
uh this is the end 17 yeah end of the
fourth year
and so it's just when you think about
how many people are willing to sit down
and just bash the head against the wall
for four years or so not many a lot of
people think they are but uh when you
get you know
to day 472 and you have to go record a
podcast and write and do all this kind
of stuff i think people just
you know say hey look there's better
stuff for me to go do so i think
consistency is definitely the uh
the differentiator yeah yeah you're very
prolific you're definitely uh one of
the top uh podcasters in my feed in
terms of just like constantly releasing
episodes
i try uh five times a week that's the uh
that's the goal
so we'll we'll see if it works oh yeah
well congratulations on getting this guy
right here top talent
exactly all right where can we send
people to uh to find you on the internet
and find
more about relationship hero uh cool
yeah so i'm gonna say
relationshiphero.com and check out my
blog
bloated bloatedmvp.com all right
bloatedmvp.com and then
uh relationshiphero.com and if you use
dot com slash
pomp what is it 50 off 50 off
all right guys go check it out and uh
thank you so much for doing this i'll do
it again in the future
thanks a lot bob appreciate it